you're embarking on on a massive tour
yeah this thing were you going to go
stadiums and like play for like 50,000
people it must be its own kind of beast
yeah I know you you're probably excited
but there's any part of that actually
terrified of it yeah every part of it
but I mean this for this is that touring
I think if I had to choose one thing in
my career to do its touring it's just
this incredible I always like to think
about touring is like you can make a
show this big ball of happiness right
and then you just like travel a world
and if you're lucky maybe that concert
can be five of the 15,000 people in the
arenas best night sure so if you're
travelling around the world and you're
making all of these people's best night
of the year it's this incredibly
positive thing and I actually realize
how much that affected my happiness and
me but there's like this really because
I haven't toured much this year like I
have in the past there's this huge thing
inside of me that's like desperate to
get back on the road and back to tour
and yeah so I'm so excited that I had
the nerves aren't really hitting me yet
yeah but when you get out there I mean
you're touring with people that you've
been working with for for years and
years yes right so when you feel those
nerves or you feel kind of you can feel
down when you're when you're out there
are you guys leaning on each other to
kind of bring things to hold early
totally it's so funny humans have this
thing when they start to feel lonely
they just isolate themselves and the
truth is that the way you have to do is
do the opposite and surround yourself
and it's there's always this like two
and a half week poet I called the two
and a half week point okay when you're
like why am I so like lonely and
depressed after two and a half weeks I
got to get back home to see my family
you're not you're just like in that mode
like oh yeah we're out here for a minute
and that's kind of when I find that me
and the band and and everyone just start
hanging so much like after the shows and
my favorite moments are like after an
incredible show when we are just in the
green room for five hours and we kind of
lose track of time and it's 1:00 a.m.
and we've all we're all still like
sweaty from the show none of us have
shower to change but there's like this
real connection there you know when did
you learn that when did you learn it
this is that what you need to do to keep
things up when you're out there people
people are the thing that's what I
realize it is it really is human the
human connection is
this the the solving factor to
loneliness and a lot of people like I
said when I say themselves but you
really have to push the opposite yeah
yeah this is gonna put you you know it
this is just me kind of looking at it
from the outside but I feel like it's
gonna put you on like the next level of
stardom do you see that really I think
at the Rogers Center is a huge thing
this is like you know when I was a kid
my dream was your dream is to play a
stadium one day and then in your home
city just makes it even bigger of a deal
yeah
now that is becoming a reality and yeah
I can't that I wish I had a way to
downplay it but there is no way to
downplay it it's around your Center it's
50,000 people and it's huge and it's
gonna be spectacular and it's kind of
everything that I worked for is up to
that moment yeah you know you've got
like a little economy going
it's like Shawn Mendes Inc yeah yeah
does it weigh on you that you know you
got people working with you and kind of
working for you and if they depend on
you totally all the time and the all of
those people only want to see you do
great you know and even like you and I
used to get so nervous to sit in front
of somebody to be like oh they don't
want to make me look bad but it's not
true you want it to look great so
everyone you know works together so I
realized that even if you are the boss
the whole point is that there's a
synergy you know to make things work
because if it doesn't work for me it
doesn't work for anyone
right and that's the pressure is on all
of us you know are you ever a tough boss
I I don't think I'm a tough boss I don't
know if you'd ask me these two view who
work for me but I don't think I am yeah
you know at this point everyone wants
something from you yeah right how do you
know who to trust I think you just kind
of have a gut feeling about it and don't
take it too seriously and the real thing
for me is I am just so I'm actually
closer today than I have ever been with
my friends from home I've known for 10
years we were on this like really
serious bond in connection that
everything that wants to pull me away
from them just makes it even stronger
and I just really kind of hold on to
that yeah you get in touch with your
family and friends often and you talk
about it - we've talked about it before
yeah when you think back to before all
of this happened
what was your picture of what Fame was
gonna be like I have no idea I don't
think you ever know because it's famous
such a vague term and it kind of means
nothing you know thing you are not an
icon or you're not a famous just because
you're famous you're famous because you
do something that you believe in you can
I think it's you you can be very you can
easily forget that the reason the famous
there is because you love music and you
love people and you love making them
happy and if you kind of just focus on
that you you be good you know yeah are
you getting advice now from people that
you have looked up to people that you've
been working with on various projects on
how to handle certain things like big
big early shows or how to handle things
like dealing with press dealing with the
audience yeah and and
all the investment all the advice in the
world is incredible the difference is
the problem is is that everybody is so
different that there's always going to
be something that's easy for me that's
hard for the next person and hard for me
and easy for the next guy and that's
never gonna change you know so you kind
of have to just make an effort to make
your own advice yeah you've said before
that you know the best advice you got
was just be yourself yeah is there a
piece of advice that you took that you
were just like yeah this doesn't work
for me yeah I'm sure and I don't
remember it because it's not worth
remembering the advice that doesn't work
but that guys yeah like be yourself
because the worst it would be worst it
would be better to not be known at all
than to be known for something you're
not for some as someone you're not you
know what I mean
and that is that's a really serious
thing to me it's love that you to be
surrounded by people and people that you
work with whether you adore the Jag but
when it's just you like when do you turn
it off at what moment he just like I
just get to be me again and not kind of
doing anything for anybody else um Allah
Allah I find that I've just served my my
parents especially my mom like my
friends everyone is very giving I've
surrounded myself with really giving
people so I feel like I receive
definitely as much as I give yeah if not
more sometimes I mean definitely from
the fans
so yeah yeah and I'm honestly did I'm a
very lucky person I have really
incredible people around me and a lot of
people don't and I'm really appreciative
that mm-hmm you know a lot of actors are
so excuse me a lot of singers are
getting into acting we've seen that at
yeah and you're you're killing it right
now at what point you can say you want
to see Shawn Mendes on the big screen
and do some active yeah I would love to
do so acting I think for me it's one I
love music too much to take a break
right now I just really adore I love
touring I love making music I love
everything about it
and I just don't want to take that break
yet but if what day comes where I'm like
you know maybe music can take a break
for a year I'd love to do some acting
because I I think acting is really
incredible mm-hmm yeah um over your
years of doing this growing and learning
about yourself and learning about the
people you're around have you ever had
to kind of cut anybody off like that
that give you bad advice or that you
know is not helping you be the best
version of yourself yeah I don't know if
I'm necessarily been like I'm cutting
you off from my life but I think yeah
and it's not it's not so much about
removing people from your life it's
about surrounding yourself with the
people who you know make you stronger
and build you you know well you get to
see you do a Grammy tribute to tell the
Parton yes but yeah they cool yeah how
excited to you is that racking to hold
sonoran Legend and my mom's listening to
Dolly Parton's as far as long as I can I
think 9 to 5 was the one of the very
first songs I ever learned all the
lyrics to em and yeah I mean so thrilled
but I think in those situations you just
have to do it the best you can mmm
that's all she would have done have you
ever heard before I've never met dolly
no that would be a dream I'm sure I
hopefully get to yeah what are you
expecting from that night or from the
for meeting her meeting her I'm sure
she's gonna be the most incredibly aware
and humble and beautiful soul because I
don't think you'd become that successful
if you're not mm-hmm
and the Grammy nominations are coming
out soon in a few days are you
anticipating getting nominated does it
matter to you I would I would be lying
if I said it didn't matter to me
obviously um is it everything that I do
and is that what it all stands for no
doesn't that stuff things sure
um and I don't know I don't know we'll
see what happens you'd ever you
definitely really don't know but I do
know that I love to play music in front
of
people and I would be much more sad if
people didn't come to the shows than if
I didn't get a Grammy nomination yeah
yeah
you